حسنًا، لا يزال الوضع على طول
الحدود الجنوبية للبنان مع إسرائيل
متوترًا، لذا يحذر الآن رئيس أركان الجيش الإسرائيلي من أنهم
مستعدون للتحول إلى
الوضع الهجومي في أي لحظة، كما يأتي في الوقت الذي يعلن فيه كل من
لبنان وإسرائيل عن سقوط
ضحايا مدنيين من ضربات يوم الأحد على طول
الحدود هناك.  كان هناك
تبادل لإطلاق النار شبه يومي هناك منذ الثامن من تشرين الأول/أكتوبر
بين إسرائيل ومسلحين مثل
حزب الله، وهذا أمر
أثار وزير الخارجية الأمريكي مخاوف عميقة
بشأنه عندما التقى برئيس الوزراء اللبناني المؤقت
في أمان الأردن
وشكره على سفينته الرائدة في منع
لبنان.  من الانجرار إلى حرب أوسع نطاقا،
فضلا عن جهود لبنان في
العمل مع الشركاء الإقليميين لتحقيق
السلام في وقت سابق، تحدثت زميلتي بيكي
أندرسون مباشرة إلى
وزير الخارجية اللبناني، إليكم بعض ما
ناقشوه وأريد أن أسأل عن ما الذي  رئيس
الوزراء ما هي
الرسالة التي أرسلها رئيس الوزراء اللبناني
إلى أنتوني بلينكن وبالفعل ما الذي
عاد إليه ولكن دعونا نبدأ
بهذه الصورة من ضربات
الحوادث على تلك الحدود أه مع
إسرائيل أم تشير التقارير إلى أن أحد
مشرعي الصباح قال ذلك
الضربة الإسرائيلية التي قتلت أطفالا في وقت سابق
اليوم هي تطور خطير
سيكون له تداعيات ما مدى
قلقك من تصريح
كهذا من أحد نواب الحزب وخطر
التصعيد في هذه المرحلة
أه أنا قلق للغاية لأن
الأطفال ثلاثة أطفال تحت  10 ثلاث
فتيات صغيرات تحت سن 10 سنوات ومع
جدتهن أصيبوا بطائرة بدون طيار
وكانوا يقودون سياراتهم نحو بيروت
هاربين من المشاكل في الجنوب،
لذلك هو حقًا في كل لبنان ليس
فقط لينون كله منزعج حقًا
من هذا أه  الوضع أه
كانوا يقاتلون بعضهم البعض والعسكريون
يقاتلون بعضهم البعض والآن يذهب
للمدنيين والسيارة المدنية متجهة
نحو بيروت وقد ضربتها
طائرة إسرائيلية بدون طيار وأه نحن دائما
نخشى أن تبدأ الحرب هكذا
بنعم  في خطابه الأول، وقد أوضحت
نقطة جيدة للغاية، إن أي شرارة في هذه
المرحلة يمكن أن تزيد المخاطر حقًا في
أول خطاب كبير له منذ بدء هذه الحرب، حذر
حسن ناسالا، رئيس
حزب الله، من حرب إقليمية إذا
لم يتوقف هذا الهجوم  غزة
وقال إنه يحمل الولايات المتحدة
مسؤولية ما يجري في غزة، ولم
يصل إلى حد الالتزام
بحرب أوسع نطاقا، وتحدث مرة أخرى يوم السبت،
ما رأيك في تعليقاته وهل
تشاركه الرأي القائل بأنه كذلك؟
ينأى بنفسه إلى حد ما في هذه
المرحلة عن
العمل بشكل جيد
منذ البداية، لقد
أجرت الحكومة الكثير من المفاوضات
مع حزب الله وآخرين
في الجبهة في جنوب لبنان وأه نحن
تحت الانطباع
وهم  لم يخبرنا ولكن لدينا
انطباع بأنه لن تكون هناك أي
حرب كبيرة قادمة إلا إذا هاجمت إسرائيل
لبنان أو أصبح الوضع
سيئًا جدًا جدًا في غزة الآن ما أه ما
قاله حسن بالأمس لم يتغير
منذ البداية  لكنه أوضح ذلك
جيدًا بالأمس لجميع المعنيين، لذلك
أه نحن لسنا كذلك ولكن لا أعرف ما الذي
سيحدث الآن، كما تعلم أنه لا يمكنك
أبدًا معرفة ما سيحدث في مثل هذه الظروف
لأن حادثة واحدة صغيرة
يمكن أن تبدأ حربًا، كما تعلم نأمل ألا يحدث ذلك
اللبنانيون لا يريدون الحرب لا أعتقد أن
الحسبة يريد الحرب لكن أه وكما
قالوا لم يعلموا بالهجوم
الذي قامت به حماس فهذا لا يعني
أنه لا علاقة لهم
بحماس ولكنهم لا يعرفون  ما
بدأوه لا نريد حرباً في
لبنان ونأمل ألا
يبدأ الإسرائيليون معنا حرباً